how's it going everyone my name's Pierre
and welcome back um Nisha
there we go them recording out there was
a bug if you remember I jump down the
stairs by accident and that [ __ ] up
everything but I walked up the stairs
and then all the sudden is like action
so I'm I have to break escape when you
have start running and it's gonna be
scary enough but ah ah stairs oh I
shouldn't have ah he really wants me to
put it back I think oh well I think I
should have shouldn't have ate so many
chicken
she can make Nargis I need ads here
uh-huh
so now you see it's different and now
this door repaired
now it wears oh well
super weird room is super weird I have a
meatball no okay let's go to the great
great great great what's shaking and
grand finally you can go I don't know I
don't know I don't know and I don't
understand why it's like this I mean
it's gotta be a Verya
amia whoa ma is after me let's be the
music oh [ __ ] ah huh shadows everywhere
go where they go there we go
oh [ __ ] you out don't hit me bro
don't hit me bro don't hit me bro don't
hit me bro let's go down here cuz I'm
just like looks like a good place to go
down oh don't hit Pipper [ __ ] I
shouldn't Alou
are you sure not look back you have to
carry out I know I died like a million
times I know I have to carry out you
guys expect me to carry out and I have
to run again go pootie go pootie go go
go go
let's take a shortcut bad idea hi
actually good idea let's go
I'm booked no I'm not okay we're good
now we will go through goo really go
through the Piron I'll play door right
here and maybe not maybe I have to place
an alien artifact first no I play stahma
plays in my orb nope doesn't worry
[ __ ]
we're going to realm' four okay it says
go here okay I can't go here maybe in
here Oh
I don't think it's in here but now you
never know it's green lightning nope not
in here oh the door totally closed on
itself super creepy hmm I wonder why
that never dust like every scary movie
ever made the door closes behind
themself but not in this game the door
does not close by chill they just open
and stuff I guess so I place it here
maybe oh wow
you're floating nice school to the
outfall yes yes I wonder if you'll see
the Brona wait we already seen the room
face
I don't know singham your news by the
way someone punching it
we're here
go here Scully
an OPP so how you been I'm disappointed
that you I don't need one
okay why I can tell it's a long story
all went to the hip as a bird they were
like we should go to the inner sanctum I
gotta call you back
come on it's dark I can't move Percy I
can't leave I can surely Rama could move
what is this this is really creepy madam
walking in oh I ate stairs there's so
many I shouldn't have it when they asked
for chicken McNuggets nice at nine I
should have said six
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I worked up a lot of stairs
and what have you felt down here I want
to have a night like a mattress and then
just kind of that would be us family
together and the problem I don't trust
you
there I don't trust you either and the
water this is like good old times in the
water like I was like oh I'm scared and
I did or whatever how we're leaving
we're super slow-mo walk why am I so
slow ilysm I found 10 or 11 notes
I guess we're finished how does he creep
you
I'm vanishing better believe it
get out finish a show through the portal
kind of boring I might do something
extra for you guys I was currently like
I'm like we you know I'm a [ __ ]
walking paradox no I'm not threesomes
with a [ __ ] Triceratops
Reptar rapping as a mark and def rock
stars - exotic wigs made of n wash